je suis fou là toi je vais faire
l'émission de thierry ardisson
tu trouves pas quand on est un peu trop
à la télé c'est ce qui se dit j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] je fais comme je veux si
on le voyait
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez pas assez à 27 pour moi on a
petit tête c'est parce que tu vas plus
lent et bistrots comptent 300 heures à
la télé non ont pour l intérêt parce
qu'on me le demande
et puis quand on est resté longtemps à
porte ont fait on fait tout quoi on a
envie de tout faire en tant qu'acteur
c'est du dépôt devant vidal sa relance
un petit peu le schmilblick jésus bien
aimé travailler avec gilles à ben j'ai
téléphoné au bureau on m'a dit ça fait 2
millions de téléspectateurs soit la
france déjà et comme c'est un film que
j'aime bien je suis très content
les critiques ils ont dit que le film
était formidable parce qu'il y avait
moins de boire un jury qu'avant c'est
quoi une boiserie c'est quoi tomber les
grilles
après cette émission tas d'autres grands
projets ouais j'ai pas tourné deux films
depuis depuis une époque formidable
j'ai une espèce d'appétit l'espèce de
boulimie on a su faire trop film de
jérôme boivin mémoire d'un bar jean
claude miller l'accompagnatrice c'est le
fils de patrice leconte
philippe noiret et thierry lhermitte et
après je ferai mon film tiré de mon
bouquin et ça tu sais bien c'est pas de
la tarte
sinon ça te fais pas chier toile et je
vais rater les jeux coeur
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu